[Music]
memories are fragile
i want us to sketch out the right man we
just need enough details for someone who
knows
it won't work no one knows him
[Music]
anchored this morning city workers found
a body from a young woman called julia
[Music]
six years ago i was caught up like her
what someone did to julia they tried it
into you
if you're trying to be a reporter
then this is your story
after what he did
things aren't how they should be
it starts with little things
and then big things
and nobody remembers anything different
there are multiple women dead over
multiple decades
he's the one connecting them
there'll be more
i don't know how but he's been watching
me
since i was a kid
he's everybody
he's nobody
he's all the time
just because something hasn't happened
doesn't mean it won't
work all connected
things change for me just
like that
and then it happens again
and again and again
you shouldn't be here
what's his name
who's the man who visits you
[Music]
you